- [Kelly] Thank you for being here.
Have y'all met before?
- No, well we-
- Y'all never met?
- No, but you scared me
- We never met.
many nights watching "The X-Files."
- Oh good. All right then.
(all laughing)
- Oh, this theme music. I'm
like, "Oh, sometime now."
(everyone laughing)
But I grew up watching you.
Not to say, we're probably
close in age, but I grew up.
- Well, I don't know.
- Well, black don't crack
but my knees do hurt.
(everyone laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Don't brag about it.
(laughing)
Oh my God.
So, you've had just a remarkable life
that could fill volumes
and make amazing movies.
Do you have a speed version
that you could give us?
- Yeah Kelly, I had two
kids by the time I was 15,
dropped out of high school,
got shot a couple times,
got hit by a dump truck
and turned it all around,
now laugh about it.
- Oh my- (laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Oh, and I lost a nipple.
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- I lost a nipple.
Two nipples are overrated.
- Who took it?
Two- (laughs)
- How many did you have to start with?
(Kelly laughing)
- I had two good ones,
but now I got one and a half.
- Oh my God. Wait, what?
- Yeah.
- That's, well God, now I,
what's your 10 second story?
(everyone laughing)
- I was born with two nipples
and I still have them.
(everyone laughing)